[Music]
all right it's christmas time at the
store
dinner what do you want for christmas
the
cake remote control car i want some i
don't want to do
this i want to come to that finger bang
class you go to god
a new car for myself to not get sued
by these two old ladies
gift certificate to domino's i'd like my
amazon
wishlist to be fulfilled nothing but a
smile man
nothing but a smile that's it you just
want to smile i mean
in a car serenity i've got
supplements i've got water be happy with
my babies
world peace a new scarf
i want a gi joe with a grip i want for
to be over can i change mine yeah what
do you want for christmas world peace
we're just talking about peace uh i
wanna i wanna
i wanna range rover i got lenny and
larry cookies it's all about
giving back to me i've got it all i
would like to have um
a photo of theovan like but not like a
photo like what are those things you
stick on the bottom of like your urinal
piece of heart peace of mind happiness
with your overall just
experience on this planet sounds [__]
gay dude i want this piece of carrot
that stuck my teeth out of my teeth
and the fitbit give me some goals man i
just want you to mold it up
give me some goals give me two at the
bottom where you want gold
oh gold teeth
you know i'm a gym oh
what i want for christmas is a dyson
hair dryer
i hear they're fantastic sheer joy and
oh one of those
uh one of those uh bags for a suit i've
got speakers
i've got drum practice pads i've got a
baseball glove
definitely don't use this close post
post now what i really want you're
married you can't have puss plus push
some big titties a new car i want a wife
um world peace i
like certain people in my life uh back
i like that virtual reality [__] have
you seen that yeah but i got an
iphone it doesn't work for them right i
don't know and dry the hair
double the time than any other hairdryer
what do you give a guy who's got
everything supplements
a day off a pony a pony i've had pony
meat before and pony once at a wedding
i want to be on or the best friend on a
sitcom that goes eight years
dude i want a hood pass i don't give a
[__] i want to [__] be able to pay my
[__] mortgage
i don't want anything for christmas i'm
an adult what do you give me a [__]
choo choo train
all right and mold it up and if i need
something i'm gonna buy my own sauce
all right so [__] you ain't chris
crinkle i could
use a bigger television set
because mine is only like canon lenses
sony lenses i want a bacon cheeseburger
and pink vaginas
i want a paddle board and i want a
motorcycle okay
my daughters are not gonna get me that
they'll give me a pillow and a pressure
cleaner
they're the shittiest gifts every
[__] year and i buy everything
everything they want and i get
[__] i get [__] every time a couple
more inches on my dick shoes
yeezys just give me shoes oh
i don't just be happy i would like my
new puppy
to stop biting the [__] out of me i want
cocaine
the other one for christmas is a big
booty hoe it's more about [__] 60
less comics and about 100 more spots
um all right so a shorter scarf you want
it to be out of cashmere i know what
they want okay what do you want
bordeaux candy from seas